das hat natürlich was schöpferisches und
auch das kraftvolle ist auf jeden fall
jedes mal extrem aufregend und ich
genieße es auch also das ist auch ein
wichtiger punkt für mich irgendwie so
dass das so körper nicht mit so viel
aufregung verbunden
[Musik]
ich habe mich einmal verletzt und dann
hat es erst mal eine pause aber ernst
hatte ich eigentlich nehmen
ich komme aus einer barock stadt
ludwigsburg hat im barockschloss und da
war es üblich bis heute dass jedes jahr
im sommer ein riesiges feuerwerk
geschossen wird und als kind war ich
schon total begeistert davon ja ich habe
mich immer nachts wecken lassen
[Musik]
ich habe hier angefangen in offenbach zu
studieren wollte auf jeden fall kunst
studieren und habe dort gezeichnet in
offenbach
ich dachte irgendwas diese zeichnungen
das waren viel so architektouren
weltraum architektouren und ich dachte
immer als ich sie angeguckt habe er das
sind modelle für irgendwas und dann
irgendwann kam es mir dass das sehr viel
ähnlichkeit mit feuerwerk hat und dann
hat sich eigentlich der wunsch
entwickelt das feuerwerk als
zeichenstift und
das was mich daran interessiert ist dass
er licht die frage wofür zerstörung an
oder kann ich aus diesem heftigen
material wie sprengstoff wirklich was
gestalten
wen zum studieren hier nach frankfurt
gekommen und bin hängen geblieben aber
auch sehr gerne also das war natürlich
dann irgendwann auch eine entscheidung
und ich habe die stadt in dieser langen
zeit jetzt doch sehr gern gewonnen muss
ich sagen also ich mag diese kontraste
zwischen den hochhäusern und diesen
gutbürgerlichen diese apfelweinkneipe
und auch absolut dieses internationale
der palmengarten zählt auf jeden fall zu
meinen lieblingsplätzen hier in
frankfurt
dass es für mich arbeitsplatz und
erholungs platz gleichermaßen
[Musik]
ich komme hier zum zeitplan und versucht
diese wahnsinnige from vielfalt in
diesen gärten skizzenhaft einzufangen
und setzt sie dann später in skulpturen
und in die feuerwerke um in abstrakter
form
[Musik]
so der ist gut verpackt
das sind raum stellen es gibt auch so
ein kleines rotes licht diese blitze und
die fontänen die machen wahnsinnig
schöne schmauchspuren vor allem diese
blick zu diesem super das ist fast wie
malerei die liebe ich die teile multi
flash nimmt sich das ja und das ist
natürlich dann so hier der wunsch zum
schluss
[Musik]
das ist eine schäbige bastelei und die
zeit entlädt sich dann eigentlich ein
feuerwerk also deshalb ist es
wahrscheinlich dass intensiv die arbeit
heißt also ein schwarzer spiegel und die
idee ist dass wir ein feuerwerk das
hinter dem monitor montiert ist schießen
und im gleichen moment wird die
übertragung auf dem monitor gezeigt das
ist der plan
ich hoffe es hat muss ok dann mann
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]